[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Well, Hal just told
us how you build robust
systems. The key idea was--
I'm sure that many of you don't
really assimilate that
yet-- but the key idea is that
in order to make a system
that's robust, it has to be
insensitive to small changes,
that is, a small change in the
problem should lead to only a
small change in the solution.
There ought to be
a continuity.
The space of solutions ought to
be continuous in this space
of problems.
The way he was explaining how
to do that was instead of
solving a particular problem
at every level of
decomposition of the problem at
the subproblems, where you
solve the class of problems,
which are a neighborhood of
the particular problem that
you're trying to solve.
The way you do that is by
producing a language at that
level of detail in which the
solutions to that class of
problems is representable
in that language.
Therefore when you makes more
changes to the problem you're
trying to solve, you generally
have to make only small local
changes to the solution you've
constructed, because at the
level of detail you're working,
there's a language
where you can express the
various solutions to alternate
problems of the same type.
Well that's the beginning of a
very important idea, the most
important perhaps idea that
makes computer science more
powerful than most of the other
kinds of engineering
disciplines we know about.
What we've seen so far
is sort of how to use
embedding of languages.
And, of course, the power of
embedding languages partly
comes from procedures
like this one that
I showed you yesterday.
What you see here is the
derivative program that we
described yesterday.
It's a procedure that takes a
procedure as an argument and
returns a procedure
as a value.
And using such things
is very nice.
You can make things like push
combinators and all that sort
of wonderful thing that
you saw last time.
However, now I'm going to
really muddy the waters.
See this confuses the issue of
what's the procedure and what
is data, but not very badly.
What we really want to do is
confuse it very badly.
And the best way to do that is
to get involved with the
manipulation of the algebraic
expressions that the
procedures themselves
are expressed in.
So at this point, I want to talk
about instead of things
like on this slide, the
derivative procedure being a
thing that manipulates
a procedure--
this is a numerical method
you see here.
And what you're seeing is
a representation of the
numerical approximation
to the derivative.
That's what's here.
In fact what I'd like to talk
about is instead things that
look like this.
And what we have here are rules
from a calculus book.
These are rules for finding
the derivatives of the
expressions that one
might write in
some algebraic language.
It says things like a derivative
of a constant is 0.
The derivative of the valuable
with respect to which you are
taking the derivative is 1.
The derivative of a constant
times the function is the
constant times the derivative
of the function,
and things like that.
These are exact expressions.
These are not numerical
approximations.
Can we make programs?
And, in fact, it's very easy
to make programs that
manipulate these expressions.
Well let's see.
Let's look at these rules
in some detail.
You all have seen these rules
in your elementary calculus
class at one time or another.
And you know from calculus
that it's easy to produce
derivatives of arbitrary
expressions.
You also know from your
elementary calculus that it's
hard to produce integrals.
Yet integrals and derivatives
are opposites of each other.
They're inverse operations.
And they have the same rules.
What is special about these
rules that makes it possible
for one to produce derivatives
easily and
integrals why it's so hard?
Let's think about that
very simply.
Look at these rules.
Every one of these rules, when
used in the direction for
taking derivatives, which is
in the direction of this
arrow, the left side is
matched against your
expression, and the right side
is the thing which is the
derivative of that expression.
The arrow is going that way.
In each of these rules, the
expressions on the right-hand
side of the rule that are
contained within derivatives
are subexpressions, are proper
subexpressions, of the
expression on the
left-hand side.
So here we see the derivative
of the sum, with is the
expression on the left-hand
side is the sum of the
derivatives of the pieces.
So the rule of moving to the
right are reduction rules.
The problem becomes easier.
I turn a big complicated problem
it's lots of smaller
problems and then combine the
results, a perfect place for
recursion to work.
If I'm going in the other
direction like this, if I'm
trying to produce integrals,
well there are several
problems you see here.
First of all, if I try to
integrate an expression like a
sum, more than one
rule matches.
Here's one that matches.
I don't know which
one to take.
And they may be different.
I may get to explore
different things.
Also, the expressions become
larger in that direction.
And when the expressions become
larger, then there's no
guarantee that any particular
path I choose will terminate,
because we will only terminate
by accidental cancellation.
So that's why integrals
are complicated
searches and hard to do.
Right now I don't want to do
anything as hard as that.
Let's work on derivatives
for a while.
Well, these roles are
ones you know for
the most part hopefully.
So let's see if we can write a
program which is these rules.
And that should be very easy.
Just write the program.
See, because while I showed you
is that it's a reduction
rule, it's something appropriate
for a recursion.
And, of course, what we have for
each of these rules is we
have a case in some
case analysis.
So I'm just going to write
this program down.
Now, of course, I'm going to be
saying something you have
to believe.
Right?
What you have to believe is I
can represent these algebraic
expressions, that I can grab
their parts, that I can put
them together.
We've invented list structures
so that you can do that.
But you don't want to worry
about that now.
Right now I'm going to write the
program that encapsulates
these rules independent of
the representation of the
algebraic expressions.
You have a derivative of
an expression with
respect to a variable.
This is a different
thing than the
derivative of the function.
That's what we saw last time,
that numerical approximation.
It's something you can't
open up a function.
It's just the answers.
The derivative of
an expression is
the way it's written.
And therefore it's a syntactic
phenomenon.
And so a lot of what we're going
to be doing today is
worrying about syntax,
syntax of expressions
and things like that.
Well, there's a case analysis.
Anytime we do anything
complicated thereby a
recursion, we presumably
need a case analysis.
It's the essential
way to begin.
And that's usually
a conditional
of some large kind.
Well, what are their
possibilities?
the first rule that you saw is
this something a constant?
And what I'm asking is, is the
expression a constant with
respect to the variable given?
If so, the result is 0,
because the derivative
represents the rate of
change of something.
If, however, the expression that
I'm taking the derivative
of is the variable I'm varying,
then this is the same
variable, the expression var,
then the rate of change of the
expression with respect
to the variable is 1.
It's the same 1.
Well now there are a couple
of other possibilities.
It could, for example,
be a sum.
Well, I don't know how I'm going
to express sums yet.
Actually I do.
But I haven't told you yet.
But is it a sum?
I'm imagining that there's
some way of telling.
I'm doing a dispatch on the type
of the expression here,
absolutely essential in
building languages.
Languages are made out of
different expressions.
And soon we're going to see
that in our more powerful
methods of building languages
on languages.
Is an expression a sum?
If it's a sum, well, we know the
rule for derivative of the
sum is the sum of the
derivatives of the parts.
One of them is called
the addend and the
other is the augend.
But I don't have enough space
on the blackboard
to such long names.
So I'll call them A1 and A2.
I want to make a sum.
Do you remember which is the sum
for end or the menu end?
Or was it the dividend
and the divisor or
something like that?
Make sum of the derivative
of the A1, I'll call it.
It's the addend of the
expression with respect to the
variable, and the derivative of
the A2 of the expression,
because the two arguments,
the addition with
respect to the variable.
And another rule that we know is
product rule, which is, if
the expression is a product.
By the way, it's a good idea
when you're defining things,
when you're defining predicates,
to give them a
name that ends in
a question mark.
This question mark doesn't
mean anything.
It's for us as an agreement.
It's a conventional interface
between humans so you can read
my programs more easily.
So I want you to, when you write
programs, if you define
a predicate procedure, that's
something that rings true of
false, it should have a name
which ends in question mark.
The list doesn't care.
I care.
I want to make a sum.
Because the derivative of a
product is the sum of the
first times the derivative of
the second plus the second
times the derivative of the
first. Make a sum of two
things, a product of, well, I'm
going to say the M1 of the
expression, and the derivative
of the M2 of the expression
with respect to the variable,
and the product of the
derivative of M1, the multiplier
of the expression,
with respect to the variable.
It's the product of that and the
multiplicand, M2, of the
expression.
Make that product.
Make the sum.
Close that case.
And, of course, I could add as
many cases as I like here for
a complete set of rules you
might find in a calculus book.
So this is what it takes to
encapsulate those rules.
And you see, you have to realize
there's a lot of
wishful thinking here.
I haven't told you anything
about how I'm going to make
these representations.
Now, once I've decided that
this is my set of rules, I
think it's time to play with
the representation.
Let's attack that/
Well, first of all, I'm
going to play a pun.
It's an important pun.
It's a key to a sort
of powerful idea.
If I want to represent sums, and
products, and differences,
and quotients, and things like
that, why not use the same
language as I'm writing
my program in?
I write my program in algebraic
expressions that
look like the sum of the product
on a and the product
of x and x, and things
like that.
And the product of b and x and
c, whatever, make that a sum
of the product.
Right now I don't want to have
procedures with unknown
numbers of arguments, a product
of b and x and c.
This is list structure.
And the reason why this is nice,
is because any one of
these objects has a property.
I know where the car is.
The car is the operator.
And the operands are the
successive cdrs the successive
cars of the cdrs of the
list that this is.
It makes it very convenient.
I have to parse it.
It's been done for me.
I'm using the embedding
and Lisp to advantage.
So, for example, let's start
using list structure to write
down the representation that I'm
implicitly assuming here.
Well I have to define various
things that are implied in
this representation.
Like I have to find out
how to do a constant,
how you do same variable.
Let's do those first. That's
pretty easy enough.
Now I'm going to be introducing
lots of primitives
here, because these are
the primitives that
come with list structure.
OK, you define a constant.
And what I mean by a constant,
an expression that's constant
with respect to a veritable,
is that the expression is
something simple.
I can't take it into
pieces, and yet
it isn't that variable.
I can't break it up, and yet
That does not mean that there
may be other expressions that
are more complicated
that are constants.
It's just that I'm going to
look at the primitive
constants in this way.
So what this is, is it says
that's it's the and.
I can combine predicate
expressions which return true
or false with and.
Something atomic, The expression
is atomic, meaning
it cannot be broken
into parts.
It doesn't have a car and a cdr.
It's not a list. It adds
a special test built
into the system.
And it's not identically
equal to that variable.
I'm representing my variable
by things that are symbols
which cannot be broken into
pieces, things like x, and y,
things like this.
Whereas, of course, something
like this can be broken up
into pieces.
And the same variable of an
expression with respect to a
variable is, in fact, an
atomic expression.
I want to have an atomic
expression, which is identical.
I don't want to look inside
this stuff anymore.
These are primitive maybe.
But it doesn't matter.
I'm using things that are given
to me with a language.
I'm not terribly interest
in them
Now how do we deal with sums?
Ah, something very interesting
will happen.
A sum is something which is not
atomic and begins with the
plus symbol.
That's what it means.
So here, I will define.
An question is a sum if and it's
not atomic and it's head,
it's beginning, its car of the
expression is the symbol plus.
Now you're about to see
something you haven't seen
before, this quotation.
Why do I have that
quotation there?
Say your name,
AUDIENCE: Susanna.
PROFESSOR: Louder.
AUDIENCE: Susanna
PROFESSOR: Say your name.
AUDIENCE: Your name.
PROFESSOR: Louder.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What I'm showing you here
is that the words
of English are ambiguous.
I was saying, say your name.
I was also possibly saying
say, your name.
But that cannot be distinguished
in speech.
However, we do have a notation
in writing, which is quotation
for distinguishing these
two possible meanings.
In particular, over here, in
Lisp we have a notation for
distinguishing these meetings.
If I were to just write a plus
here, a plus symbol, I would
be asking, is the first element
of the expression, is
the operator position
of the expression,
the addition operator?
I don't know.
I would have to have written the
addition operator there,
which I can't write.
However, this way I'm asking,
is this the symbolic object
plus, which normally stands
for the addition operator?
That's what I want.
That's the question
I want to ask.
Now before I go any further,
I want to point out the
quotation is a very complex
concept, and adding it to a
language causes a great
deal of troubles.
Consider the next slide.
Here's a deduction which we
should all agree with.
We have, Alyssa is smart and
Alyssa is George's mother.
This is an equality, is.
From those two, we can deduce
that George's mother is smart.
Because we can always substitute
equals for equals
in expressions.
Or can we?
Here's a case where we have
"Chicago" has seven letters.
The quotation means that I'm
discussing the word Chicago,
not what the word represents.
Here I have that Chicago is the
biggest city in Illinois.
As a consequence of this, I
would like to deduce that the
biggest city in Illinois
has seven letters.
But that's manifestly false.
Wow, it works.
OK, so once we have things like
that, our language gets
much more complicated.
Because it's no longer true that
things we tend to like to
do with languages, like
substituting equals for equals
and getting right answers, are
going to work without being
very careful.
We can't substitute into what's
called referentially
opaque contexts, of which a
quotation is the prototypical
type of referentially
opaque context.
If you know what that means, you
can consult a philosopher.
Presumably there is
one in the room.
In any case, let's continue now,
now that we at least have
an operational understanding of
a 2000-year-old issue that
has to do with name, and
mention, and all sorts of
things like that.
I have to define what I mean,
how to make a sum of two
things, an a1 and a2.
And I'm going to do
this very simply.
It's a list of the symbol
plus, and a1, and a2.
And I can determine
the first element.
Define a1 to be cadr. I've just
introduced another primitive.
This is the car of the
cdr of something.
You might want to know why car
and cdr are names of these
primitives, and why they've
survived, even though they're
much better ideas like
left and right.
We could have called them
things like that.
Well, first of all, the names
come from the fact that in the
great past, when Lisp was
invented, I suppose in '58 or
something, it was on a
704 or something like
that, which had a machine.
It was a machine that had an
address register and a
decrement register.
And these were the contents of
the address register and the
decrement register.
So it's an historical
accident.
Now why have these
names survived?
It's because Lisp programmers
like to talk to each other
over the phone.
And if you want to have a long
sequence of cars and cdrs you
might say, cdaddedr, which
can be understood.
But left of right or right of
left is not so clear if you
get good at it.
So that's why we have
these words.
All of them up to four deep
are defined typically in a
Lisp system.
A2 to be--
and, of course, you can see
that if I looked at one of
these expressions like the sum
of 3 and 5, what that is is a
list containing the symbol
plus, and a number 3,
and a number 5.
Then the car is the
symbol plus.
The car of the cdr. Well
I take the cdr and
then I take the car.
And that's how I get to the 3.
That's the first argument.
And the car of the cdr
of the cdr gets me to
this one, the 5.
And similarly, of course, I
can define what's going on
with products.
Let's do that very quickly.
Is the expression a product?
Yes if and if it's true, that's
it's not atomic and
it's EQ quote, the asterisk
symbol, which is the operator
for multiplication.
Make product of an M1 and an
M2 to be list, quote, the
asterisk operation
and M1 and M2.
and I define M1 to be cadr and
M2 to be caddr. You get to be
a good Lisp programmer because
you start talking that way.
I cdr down lists and console
them up and so on.
Now, now that we have
essentially a complete program
for finding derivatives,
you can add more
rules if you like.
What kind of behavior
do we get out of it?
I'll have to clear that x.
Well, supposing I define foo
here to be the sum of the
product of ax square
and bx plus c.
That's the same thing we see
here as the algebraic
expression written in the
more conventional
notation over there.
Well, the derivative of foo with
respect to x, which we
can see over here, is this
horrible, horrendous mess.
I would like it to
be 2ax plus b.
But it's not.
It's equivalent to it.
What is it?
I have here, what do I have?
I have the derivative of
the product of x and x.
Over here is, of course,
the sum of x times
1 and 1 times x.
Now, well, it's the first times
the derivative of the
second plus the second times the
derivative of the first.
It's right.
That's 2x of course.
a times 2x is 2ax plus 0X square
doesn't count plus B
over here plus a bunch of 0's.
Well the answer is right.
But I give people take off
points on an exam for that,
sadly enough.
Let's worry about that
in the next segment.
Are there any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you had left the
quote when you put the plus,
then would that be referring
to the procedure plus and
could you do a comparison
between that procedure and
some other procedure
if you wanted to?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good question.
If I had left this quotation
off at this point, if I had
left that quotation off at that
point, then I would be
referring here to the procedure
which is the thing
that plus is defined to be.
And indeed, I could compare
some procedures with each
other for identity.
Now what that means is
not clear right now.
I don't like to think
about it.
Because I don't know exactly
what it would need to compare
procedures.
There are reasons why that
may make no sense at all.
However, the symbols,
we understand.
And so that's why I
put that quote in.
I want to talk about
the symbol that's
apparent on the page.
Any other questions?
OK.
Thank you.
Let's take a break.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Well, let's see.
We've just developed a fairly
plausible program for
computing the derivatives of
algebraic expressions.
It's an incomplete program,
if you would
like to add more rules.
And perhaps you might extend
it to deal with uses of
addition with any number of
arguments and multiplication
with any of the number
of arguments.
And that's all rather easy.
However, there was a little
fly in that ointment.
We go back to this slide.
We see that the expressions that
we get are rather bad.
This is a rather
bad expression.
How do we get such
an expression?
Why do we have that
expression?
Let's look at this expression
in some detail.
Let's find out where all
the pieces come from.
As we see here, we
have a sum--
just what I showed you at the
end of the last time--
of X times 1 plus 1
time X. That is a
derivative of this product.
The produce of a times that,
where a does not depend upon
x, and therefore is constant
with respect to x, is this
sum, which goes from here all
the way through here and
through here.
Because it is the first thing
times the derivative of the
second plus the derivative of
the first times the second as
the program we wrote
on the blackboard
indicated we should do.
And, of course, the product of
bx over here manifests itself
as B times 1 plus 0 times X
because we see that B does not
depend upon X. And so the
derivative of B is this 0, and
the derivative of X with respect
itself is the 1.
And, of course, the derivative
of the sums over here turn
into these two sums of the
derivatives of the parts.
So what we're seeing here is
exactly the thing I was trying
to tell you about with Fibonacci
numbers a while ago,
that the form of the process
is expanded from the local
rules that you see in the
procedure, that the procedure
represents a set of local rules
for the expansion of
this process.
And here, the process left
behind some stuff, which is
the answer.
And it was constructed by the
walk it takes of the tree
structure, which is
the expression.
So every part in the answer we
see here derives from some
part of the problem.
Now, we can look at, for
example, the derivative of
foo, which is ax square plus
bx plus c, with respect to
other things, like here, for
example, we can see that the
derivative of foo with
respect to a.
And it's very similar.
It's, in fact, the identical
algebraic expression, except
for the fact that theses
0's and 1's are
in different places.
Because the only degree of
freedom we have in this tree
walk is what's constant with
respect to the variable we're
taking the derivative
with respect to and
was the same variable.
In other words, if we go back
to this blackboard and we
look, we have no choice what
to do when we take the
derivative of the sum
or a product.
The only interesting place here
is, is the expression the
variable, or is the expression
a constant with respect to
that variable for very, very
small expressions?
In which case we get various
1's and 0's, which if we go
back to this slide, we can see
that the 0's that appear here,
for example, this 1 over here
in derivative of foo with
respect to A, which gets us an
X square, because that 1 gets
the multiply of X and X into
the answer, that 1 is 0.
Over here, we're not taking
the derivative of foo with
respect to c.
But the shapes of these
expressions are the same.
See all those shapes.
They're the same.
Well is there anything
wrong with our rules?
No.
They're the right rules.
We've been through
this one before.
One of the things you're going
to begin to discover is that
there aren't too many
good ideas.
When we were looking at rational
numbers yesterday,
the problem was that we got
6/8 rather then 3/4.
The answer was unsimplified.
The problem, of course,
is very similar.
There are things I'd like to be
identical by simplification
that don't become identical.
And yet the rules for doing
addition a multiplication of
rational numbers were correct.
So the way we might solve this
problem is do the thing we did
last time, which always works.
If something worked last time
it ought to work again.
It's changed representation.
Perhaps in the representation
we could put in a
simplification step that
produces a simplified
representation.
This may not always
work, of course.
I'm not trying to say that
it always works.
But it's one of the pieces of
artillery we have in our war
against complexity.
You see, because we solved our
problem very carefully.
What we've done, is
we've divided the
world in several parts.
There are derivatives rules and
general rules for algebra
of some sort at this
level of detail.
and i have an abstraction
barrier.
And i have the representation of
the algebraic expressions,
list structure.
And in this barrier, I have
the interface procedures.
I have constant, and things
like same-var.
I have things like
sum, make-sum.
I have A1, A2.
I have products and things
like that, all the other
things I might need for various
kinds of algebraic
expressions.
Making this barrier allows me
to arbitrarily change the
representation without changing
the rules that are
written in terms of that
representation.
So if I can make the problem
go away by changing
representation, the composition
of the problem
into these two parts has
helped me a great deal.
So let's take a very simple
case of this.
What was one of the problems?
Let's go back to this
transparency again.
And we see here, oh yes, there's
horrible things like
here is the sum of an
expression and 0.
Well that's no reason to think
of it as anything other than
the expression itself.
Why should the summation
operation have
made up this edition?
It can be smarter than that.
Or here, for example, is
a multiplication of
something by 1.
It's another thing like that.
Or here is a product of
something with 0, which is
certainly 0.
So we won't have to make
this construction.
So why don't we just do that?
We need to change the way
the representation
works, almost here.
Make-sum to be.
Well, now it's not something
so simple.
I'm not going to make a list
containing the symbol plus and
things unless I need to.
Well, what are the
possibilities?
I have some sort
of cases here.
If I have numbers, if
anyone is a number--
and here's another primitive
I've just introduced, it's
possible to tell whether
something's number--
and if number A2, meaning
they're not symbolic
expressions, then why not
do the addition now?
The result is just a
plus of A1 and A2.
I'm not asking if these
represent numbers.
Of course all of these symbols
I'm talking about whether
the one I've got is the
number 3 right now.
And, for example, supposing A1
is a number, and it's equal to
0, well then the answer
is just A2.
There is no reason to
make anything up.
And if A2 is a number,
and equal A20, then
the result is A1.
And only if I can't figure out
something better to do with
this situation, well, I can
start a list. Otherwise I want
the representation to be the
list containing the quoted
symbol plus, and A1, and A2.
And, of course, a very
similar thing
can be done for products.
And I think I'll avoid
boring you with them.
I was going to write it
on the blackboard.
I don't think it's necessary.
You know what to do.
It's very simple.
But now, let's just see the kind
of results we get out of
changing our program
in this way.
Well, here's the derivatives
after having just changed the
constructors for expressions.
The same foo, aX square plus bX
plus c, and what I get is
nothing more than the derivative
of that is 2aX plus
B.
Well, it's not completely
simplified.
I would like to collect
common terms and sums.
Well, that's more work.
And, of course, programs to do
this sort of thing are huge
and complicated.
Algebraic simplification, it's
a very complicated mess.
There's a very famous program
you may have heard of called
Maxima developed at MIT in the
past, which is 5,000 pages of
Lisp code, mostly the algebraic
simplification
operations.
There we see the derivative
of foo.
In fact, X is at something I
wouldn't take off more than 1
point for on an elementary
calculus class.
And the derivative of foo with
respect to a, well it's gone
down to X times X, which
isn't so bad.
And the derivative of foo with
respect to b is just X itself.
respect to c comes out 1.
So I'm pretty pleased
with this.
What you've seen is, of
course, a little bit
contrived, carefully organized
example to show you how we can
manipulate algebraic
expressions, how we do that
abstractly in terms of abstract
syntax rather than
concrete syntax and how we can
use the abstraction to control
what goes on in building
these expressions.
But the real story isn't just
such a simple thing as that.
The real story is, in fact, that
I'm manipulating these
expressions.
And the expressions are
the same expressions--
going back to the slide--
as the ones that are
Lisp expressions.
There's a pun here.
I've chosen my representation
to be the same as the
representation in my language
of similar things.
By doing so, I've invoked
a necessity.
I created the necessity to have
things like quotation
because of the fact that my
language is capable of writing
expressions that talk about
expressions of the language.
I need to have something that
says, this is an expression
I'm talking about rather than
this expression is talking
about something, and I want
to talk about that.
So quotation stops and says,
I'm talking about this
expression itself.
Now, given that power, if I can
manipulate expressions of
the language, I can begin to
build even much more powerful
layers upon layers
of languages.
Because I can write languages
that not only are embedded in
Lisp or whatever language you
start with, but languages that
are completely different, that
are just, if we say,
interpreted in Lisp or
something like that.
We'll get to understand those
words more in the future.
But right now I just want to
leave you with the fact that
we've hit a line which gives
us tremendous power.
And this point we've bought
a sledgehammer.
We have to be careful to what
flies when we apply it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]